[Musique]
du
bonjour la réunion bonjour le monde
comment ils les autres et bien vous
allez bien aujourd'hui en fait on est
pas dans les eaux regardez j'ai mes bras
dehors il fait un peu beau on est à la
ravine des cabris
on est chez kevin et en doux et ils vont
nous parler de citron de tout de mariée
de citron et surtout du citron les plus
majestueux mais plus rares j'ai dit le
gîte ronde à liart et oui venez avec moi
les enfants venez venez venez
[Musique]
alors où est tu linde ou comment il est
mort né reviendra bien oui merci la
fringe ou de rien c'est leur dire voilà
ai dit mon petit plus beau ça nous met à
nu les sur la ligne des bambous sur le
site de la pépinière et la mise sur le
site de la production d'accord et il
paraît coup fait un temps dans les
titres oui s'il ne fait un regard un peu
tous les agrumes en général mais
beaucoup de marques et de citron
notamment est un caviar le citron galley
le cac saison le leem de tahiti et deux
variétés en connaît quoi nous ne nommons
tomates ou sa petite fille et bons
ballons bon on va déjà le citron caviar
avec devine mais ce soir ni chez nos
savants ne fera plus partie aux offices
[Musique]
à l'aller citron caviar on a des trucs
les bons la maturité il n'ad'autre
l'encore petit répété que son cas il
donne toute l'année sérieusement à bari
ben ouais la preuve
super sympathique ce petit arbre dit
voilà combien là combien de temps ça me
rase atteint un pic qui tombe alors à
pied comme ça on a environ 1 en 2001 1
ni un ennui voire deux ans mais il
faudrait qu'au bout d'un an on les
commence à donner ses premiers fruits
d'accord et sur l'exploitation on en a
des plus vieux et des plus anciennes se
pose alors le malheureusement les plus
jeunes a pas gardé parce que c'était un
phénomène de mode
et là tous les gens ils voulaient des
pieds plus âgés de ces partis à mâcher
des particuliers et c'est vrai bien chez
nous après personnellement on a des
pieds les plus anciens prochainement
dans ce domaine de mode
séverine citron caviar personne ne
connaissait vraiment donné l'arrivée la
réunion on a dix minutes ils font ça
vient exactement
[Musique]
pas plus qu'ailleurs
est ce que par rapport aux autres citron
inona des dunes on a des particularités
confrontés est ce qu'on en a est-ce que
voilà est-ce qu'on a un moment spécial
ou alors vraiment les fa si la poussée
est ce que damon scouts cela a donné que
les agrumes faut toujours plantes en
place lignes sont à mettre les dalons
parce que certaines personnes aient
failli dire à l'homme est escorté de
bava pouces mais non en plein soleil
wayne en plein cela ici plus le soleil
puis cela la photosynthèse et du snav
voici donc les pareil quant aux plantes
ali plein soleil mettens pu signer boeuf
fumier l'amendement organique
après l'expo de traitement je dîne à
peine produits bio savon noir les trucs
comme ça pour qu'au chili pour lafuma
chine et ces mêmes idéaux il pas plus
compliqué qu'un est à cultiver et là bas
comment les charges et hâter la highway
piétons je suis entre le fruit déjà
c'est un citron mais voit que lui
poussant long et pousse normal
pratiquement et dites-moi ce que la
particularité qui trôna par rapport aux
autres alors qu en pâture était de ceux
ci seront là quand presque en quatre
saisons par exemple un citron galets
quand on va couper le jus il ya plein
juliusson ghana débit d'accord comme nos
travers des billes et quelques agrémenté
avec à la cuisine un citron comme ça va
bien que c'est mon pote de codina ce
goût du citron même alors il se sentit
senti un coup a déjà je devais aller dit
tout un leader
déjà dix ans à la cisr un nicolas et son
le descente depuis de la lune en bout
ils savent pas où en lieu sûr
[Musique]
pendant neuf ans avant d'aller alors
dire un coup ça nous l'a alors la nuit
dans une serre elle n'a que des tags aux
mains puisera qualité agrumes alors là
où il n'a ne commence pas le citron
caviar tonga les uns des peuples mousse
tangorre après une la mandarine et
apprenants seront 400 alors l'on me
montre hall et les jeunes plants son
caviar mais voilà les comme ça alors ça
c'est des jeunes plants en a combien de
temps après alors ça les tigres effet ce
micro du progress a à ce stade là non
environ neuf mois la 9è six mois l'hymne
à la joie ça ça les greffés et après
cette fois pas oublié parce qu'il se
cogne me ht de plans des foyers
dépendent citron avec nos scandale et
son caviar ban est oublié d'enlever le
goût moment là on voit le il a ça c'est
une grâce et une vache à lait et tout ce
qu'ils sont en dessous on l'est un
courage vraiment que la brosse qu'elle
était blessée
d'accord d'accord y ont recours ce futur
à là ils mettent à le photographier
[Musique]
alors déjà comment on l'a découvert
cette variété plutôt là parce que non
encore quelques années personne qui au
courant de cette cette variété mais
c'est à la rényon
parce que c'est lui a aussi la réunion
non en coop plein d'haïti la même que ne
connais pas encore parce que les vieux
d'avant mais a constaté fait des
pratiques l'enclos grain est confronté
avec dale free à certaines dates à faire
un nouveau truc
et quant au ghana les vieilles
qu'aujourd'hui où trouver encore des
trucs que nous connaît pas encore de
cuisson cas bien c'était bien quelqu'un
l'avait la réunion sera épié et un joli
mais si par l'agglo de salon ne te
connais pas trop il ya un manège foot
nous l'a 9 800 cas qu'elle a commencé
comme ça avec des échanges
hélas nous ne développerons cabient
[Musique]
n'aime pas ce rôle et à kevin commune et
kevin jour sera bien là bien ça va
savoir auquel bon venu l'essai était
leur part fait plus tarder et sans débat
arrive alors la dicom sa hausse à
montanou comment il se fait à la grèce
oui mais un grand bond au ballon qui
tombe bien nous consommions période de
graissage alors me présente à cette note
responsable d'exploitation david ont
chanté david comment il est d'avis
travail et d'appâts personnes nous
aurons des plus de regarder peut-être
quatre émissions est assez dangereux
donc il faut casser concentrés dans la
commune et y voit que les entraîneurs
c'est la greffe d'un camp david en train
de freiner d'y préparer le pont de grès
le programme déjà c'est quoi le progrès
en fait sous le bien si un citron
sauvage appelée l'avocat mejia c'est
comme on voit lui enlève tout ce qu'ils
y ai ping et feuilles à une certaine
distance
alors là david jaffe une entaille
d'entre eux et trois centimes en france
8 va prendre son horizon cagliari la
prese année les résultats dans le temps
de venir à la barre à l'enseignement
[Musique]
alors kévin est il mort d'exploitation
ça va 5 1 hectares voilà les colombiens
dis moi combien de ces tient sur un
hectare ici en disant nous on veut nous
l'a mis en place une quinzaine dessert
environ une quinzaine de ses 15 ou nana
nous convient de son foyer beauce examen
du beau sexe alors là nous avons trois
employés après minuit n'a même moi et
mon frère voulu nous aussi nous
participe aux travaux et apprennent à
mon papa aussi qui viennent à nous aucun
tigre et la vie d'un petit peu tout ça
voilà donc la nouvelle petite endroits
aménagés pour les pois les emplois et
les employés et pose un souci c'est
profiter un petit peu quand même c'est
tous les dimanches
alors me voir sur la table nana na na là
on est différent variété de titres on
fait tout cela ou l'ena il est encore
jeune elle en accueille ce matin j'ai
arrêté de citron qu'on va trouver sur
l'exploitation
alors ça sera comme n'y a pas à ça ici à
réunion y appelle ici ton chinois simon
chinois sinon mais son nom c'est le cas
la mode dans le monde d'accord lahoud et
naba c'est la même chose c'est à dire
que saqqara mondain mais comme vous
voient la couleur sa particularité c'est
la nage en panache et là on retrouve
pareil une autre variété de citron
panache et ce sont quatre saisons mais
en plein match et il m'a arrêté titre on
galets sont belles et rodrigues
ici le titre normal c'est d'y aller ce
sont quatre saisons pouvoir retrouver la
plupart existants sur le marché
et au milieu le fameux citron caviar
vers le meilleur citron pour faire un
rougail aller c'est le cas la veille -5
à un monde on est entièrement d'accord
mais bon vous du jeu au pied des citrons
cette saison
[Musique]
paris que nous happer par un psy qui
pour nous ça me rase atteint un peu
comment es tu es con kabila
[Musique]
ou ou étant en fait
si c'est sec au moment où on met deux
bouchons dineen la fois rien mdcu croire
notre équipe est comment de la commencer
à travailler
cette fois l'histoire que ce lieu alors
estat ce lieu déjà nous dire que comme
on est venu un mot pour ce métier mais
c'est un peu à cause de notre pape alors
que les quais déjà dans le domaine a
déjà une trentaine d'années la crise et
comment dans cette branche à -2 puis
mettez à l'école ils savaient que je ne
voulais être définies pour nashville pas
après ce colin masse le lycée agricole
de saint joseph et l'amener à commencer
à travailler passer 2005 dans
l'entreprise jusqu'à ce jour à ce que
cela commence tout de suite par les
agrumes ou alors justement nous est
proposé d'engager ce que vous avez aussi
bas dans des toiles de jardins et
terrasses étaient vraiment que alors en
2000 en 97 ans c'était plus sur les
fruits sucrés a longtemps cru longtemps
que l'été ouvriers ben écoute mon milieu
de metz beaucoup finissent à 28,3 en
avant les bons points avant de prendre
l'avantagé
pour une fois la route et puis même les
autres bon appétit mais si nous
retrouvons à l'école
allez je parte
ça bougeait beaucoup à la prochaine ne
retrouve messieurs dames et voilà les
amis
l'émission se termine je vous avoue un
petit truc hein entre temps je suis
allée comme prendre un petit mot sur ton
que quiconque à diar parce que je
trouvais pas je suis désolé mais je
pouvais pas donc voilà on était sûr
était à là mais on va continuer à vous
emmener chez les producteurs avec des
produits bien 100 x 100 local et bien
sûr ma ma au lieu d'accepter un citron
il saute chez paula baala voyage suis
pas bosser l'avion une à nice nana un
autant consommée localement on a des
bons produits locaux
il faut prendre nous lé pas plus nou ne
l'est pas moins non plus enfin voyons
bon moi je vais dire au revoir ou à la
prochaine je vais rentrer chez moi et
vous connaissez le truc vous connaissez
des petits trucs on est pas du tout
sorti de l'auberge mais alors pas du
tout pas du tout mais pas du tout
[Musique]